I'm here with Brielin Brown, who works on quantum computing.
So Brielin, what does quantum physics have to do with computing?
Quantum physics actually has a lot to do with computing.
If you think about the algorithms that you've been learning about in your course
for searching the Web and doing things like this, everything that you program
is built on a fundamental model of computing that manipulates a registry of 0s and 1s.
Everything is transformed into machine instructions to manipulate these bits.
But in quantum computing, you actually get to replace these bits
with something called qubits, which give you a lot more power.
What can you do with a qubit that you can't do with a regular bit?
With regular bits they're either 0 or 1 and there's no middle ground,
but with a quantum bit you can actually exist in a superposition of 0 and 1.
So right now I have this coffee cup
which the viewer doesn't know whether or not it has any coffee in it.
So right now it exists in a superposition of being filled and unfilled until I measure,
a.k.a. take a sip.
And so you can see that there is coffee in this cup.
The cool thing about quantum information is that it takes a lot more classical information
to describe the same system.
But at the end of a quantum algorithm, to get the access for this information
you have to take a measurement which actually destroys the system.
So if you're really clever with how you devise your algorithm,
you can sort of access this exponential amount of information
in a way that allows you to solve a problem faster
by making a correct measurement at the end.
And so this allows you to do things like factor integers faster
or simulate quantum systems, which gives you a lot of progress in physics
that we haven't been able to see recently.
Wow. All this talk about physics is making me thirsty.
I think it's time to go get a coffee. >>[laughs] Absolutely.